.
ANOTHER TRAGIC EXAMPLE OF SOFT
ON CRIME POLICIES IN AMERICA.
POLICE ARRESTING A 19-YEAR-OLD
GUNMAN WHO WENT ON A SEVERAL
HOUR RAMPAGE IN MEMPHIS KILLING
FOUR PEOPLE AND INJURING THREE
ALL WHILE STREAMING THE SICK ACT
ON FACEBOOK.
SURPRISE SURPRISE THE PERP NO
STRANGER TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
COURT RECORDS SHOW A SLEW OF
CHARGINGS IN 2020 AND HE WAS
SENTENCED TO THREE YEARS IN
PRISON BUT RELEASED AFTER
SERVING 11 MONTHS IN JAIL.
EVEN THE DEMOCRATIC MAYOR THINKS
THE LACK SENTENCE IS TO BLAME.
LISTEN.
>> IF HE SERVED HIS FULL THREE
YEAR SENTENCE, HE'D STILL BE IN
PRISON TODAY AND FOUR OF OUR
FELLOW CITIZENS WOULD STILL BE
ALIVE.
>> THE CHARGE HE WAS IN FOR,
JUDGE, IT WAS AN ATTEMPTED
MURDER CHARGE, WASN'T IT?
>> YEAH, AND THEY REDUCED TO
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT.
THE SENTENCE WAS THREE YEARS.
HE CAME OUT AFTER 11 MONTHS.
YOU SEE, TENNESSEE JUST THREE
MONTHS GO PAST THE TRUTH AND
SENTENCING LAW.
I FOUND THIS OUT WHEN I WAS
FIRST A JUDGE.
I WOULD SENTENCE SOMEONE TO X
NUMBER OF YEARS AND THEY'D BE
ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE AND I'D GET
THE REQUEST SAYING I JUST
SENTENCED THAT GUY.
THERE'S NO TRUTH IN SENTENCING
IN MOST STATES IN THIS COUNTRY,
THERE'S A BENEFIT GIVEN FOR GOOD
TIME, WHATEVER THE HELL THAT
MEANS LIKE IF YOU DON'T STAB OR
SHIV YOUR NEIGHBOR AND ATTEMPTED
MURDER DOWN TO AGGRAVATED
ASSAULT AND WE'RE TAKING PLEA
BARGAINS LIKE CRAZY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO TRY CASES AND LIKE
THE SUCKER PUNCH IN NEW YORK WAS
AN ATTEMPTED MURDER AND NOW DOWN
TO MISDEMEANOR AND MISDEMEANOR
THE MOST HE'LL SERVE IS A YEAR
AND HE WON'T SERVE THAT.
NOW WHAT WE'VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND
IS THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IS NOT JUST BROKEN FROM THE
OFFENDERS BEING RELEASED AS SOON
AS THEY'RE ARRESTED BUT IT'S
BROKEN BECAUSE OF PLEA BARGAINS,
BECAUSE OF PAROLE, PROBATION.
WHEN SOMEONE IS PUT ON
PROBATION, THEY'RE IN TOUCH WITH
THEIR PROBATION OFFICER, I'VE
GOT NEWS FOR YOU.
WHAT THEY DO IS IF THEY'RE
LUCKY, THEY CALL UP THE
PROBATION OFFICER LOSES THEM AND
DOESN'T FILE A FILE OF
PROBATION.
THE WHOLE SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND
THE ONLY QUESTION IS HOW LONG
WILL IT TAKE FOR THE PENDULUM TO
SWING BACK WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE
AND THAT IS WHERE THERE'S
CONSEQUENCES AND LET ME SAY, I'M
SORRY, JUST GOT TO SAY ONE MORE
THING, THE MEMPHIS CASE, THE
ELIZA FLETCHER CASE, THE TEACHER
KIDNAPPED AND MURDERED.
THIS GUY CLEOTHA WHATEVER.
HE SHOULD NEVER BE OUT.
THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND,
THERE'S SOME PEOPLE THAT DO NOT
DESERVE TO LIVE WHERE
LAW-ABIDING PEOPLE LIVE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE EXHIBITED SO
MUCH VIOLENCE, SO MUCH DISREGARD
FOR THE LIFE OF OTHER PEOPLE
THAT THEY DON'T -- THEY
SHOULDN'T BE WITH US.
WE DID IT WITH PEDOPHILES IN NEW
YORK.
I FOUGHT FOR THE LAW IN NEW YORK
SO THAT IF YOU GOT A PEDOPHILE
THAT SERVED HIS TIME, ALL RIGHT,
THEN YOU SAY, WAIT A MINUTE,
THEY'RE PEDOPHILES.
THEY'RE GOING TO COME OUT AND
REOFFEND.
THERE'S A LAW IN NEW YORK WHICH
ALLOWS THEM TO PUT THEM INTO A
SECURED HOSPITAL WHERE THEY
CAN'T GET OUT BECAUSE THEY ARE
SO OBSESSED, THEY'RE ONLY GOING
TO MOLEST MORE CHILDREN.
WE NEED TO DO THAT WITH THESE
REOFFENDERS.
>> THIS IS A MASS SHOOTING.
YOU DON'T REALLY HEAR THE SAME
LEVEL OF LEFT WING OR MEDIA
OUTRAGE FOR THIS, DO YOU, GREG?
>> YOU CAN'T BECAUSE THE DEMS
ARE BUSY CREATING A IDEA OF
CIVIL WAR.
THERE'S VIOLENT CRIME RELEASED
BY VIOLENT CRIMINALS AND
BASICALLY POLITICIANS AND
POLITICAL LEADERS ARE PLAYING
RUSSIAN ROULETTE WITH THE PUBLIC
AND THEY'RE DROPPING THESE
BULLETS INTO SOCIETY AND IT
MIGHT HIT YOU, WHO KNOWS.
WE DON'T -- THE THING ABOUT
THIS, WE DON'T HAVE TO GIN UP A
FANTASY WAR.
YOU DON'T NEED HYPERBOLE WHEN A
WOMAN GETS PUSHED IN FRONT OF A
SUBWAY.
THAT TRUMPS TRUMPE ES AND THAT
TRUMPS JANUARY 6 AND THERE WAS A
MACHETE TEE ATTACK IN NEW YORK
CITY.
I REPEAT, MACHETE ATTACK IN NYC
AND REPEAT ATTACK BY A REPEAT
OFFENDER WHO WAS RELEASED AFTER
A MACHETE ATTACK AND SHE WAS
ONLY 20.
MY QUESTION IS, AND IT'S LIKE
THE JUDGES, WHEN DO YOU START
CHARGING D AS AND JUDGES WITH
THE CRIMES THAT THE PEOPLE THEY
RELEASE COMMIT BECAUSE YOU GOT
TO TIE THE CONSEQUENCES TO THEIR
DECISIONS.
>> YEAH, WE KNOW THE JUDGE WHO
WAS INVOLVED, WE KNOW THE DA WHO
WAS INVOLVED.
YOU DON'T PLEA DOWN AN ATTEMPTED
MURDER ONE TO 11 MONTHS.
DANA.
>> THERE WAS A ELECTION EARLIER
THIS SUMMER IN THAT COUNTY FOR
DA AND MORE CONSERVATIVE PERSON
LOST THE RACE.
I DON'T KNOW ALL THE PARTICULARS
OF THAT BECAUSE IT'S INTERESTING
WHEN YOU HAVE LOCAL CRIMES LIKE
THIS ONE, SOMETHING LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY AND PAST
THREE DAYS.
DAYS IN MEMPHIS WOULD HAVE
MADE NATIONAL NEWS 20 YEARS AGO
BUT NOW IT'S SO FRONT AND CENTER
AND WHAT'S IT LIKE IF YOU'RE
LIVING IN MEMPHIS.
HAROLD FORD JR. IS FROM MEMPHIS
AND I WAS TALKING TO HIM LAST
NIGHT AND HE SAID MY CITY IS
BROKEN AND GRIEVING AND GRIPPED
WITH VIOLENCE.
CLAY TRAVIS WAS NEARLY BREAKING
DOWN IN TEARS DISCUSSING THE
CITY'S VIOLENT CRIME WAVE AND
ONE THING IF YOU TAKE BACK TO
THE POLITICAL POLICY PROCESS,
THE REPUBLICANS ARE ABOUT TO
COME OUT WITH A NEW, FOR LACK OF
A BETTER WORD, CONTRACT WITH
AMERICA, THAT'S SEPTEMBER 19.
KEVIN MCCARTHY WILL RELEASE THAT
AND I READ A BIT ABOUT IT
YESTERDAY AND ONE OF THE FIRST
TENANTS IS RESTORING NATIONAL
SAFETY FOR LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS
AND THAT SHOULD BE JOB NUMBER
ONE.
>> IT WOULD BE GREAT IF
REPUBLICANS CAN JOIN WITH
DEMOCRATS AND BOTH BE TOUGH ON
CRIME.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT MAYOR
MIKE BLOOMBURG WAS FAMOUS FOR
AND CREATED THE CONSORTIUM OF
MAYORS AND TALKED ABOUT GUN
VIOLENCE AND HOW TO KEEP THE
CITIES SAFE.
WHAT'S BEEN INTERESTING TO TRACK
AND I'VE SAID THIS A FEW TIMES
OVER THE LAST YEAR WHERE YOU SEE
THIS DICHOTOMY BETWEEN WHAT THE
DAS ARE SAYING AND MAYORS ARE
SAYING OR POLICE CHIEFS ARE
SAYING AND WHEN THEY'RE GETTING
INTERNAL PRESSURE FROM PEOPLE OR
FROM THE SAME PARTY, I WONDER IF
THINGS START TO SHIFT.
I DO THINK THAT HAVING THIS
CLEAR LINE BETWEEN LIKE WHAT THE
MAYOR -- THE DEMOCRATIC MAYOR
LAID OUT THERE, THIS DECISION
WAS MADE TO LET HIM OUT AT 11
MONTHS AND THESE PEOPLE ARE DEAD
BECAUSE OF THAT OR WITH WHAT
HAPPENED IN NEW YORK WITH SUCKER
PUNCH GUY WITH KATHY HOCHUL HAD
TO GET UP THERE AND FIX WHAT THE
BRONX DA HAD DONE.
>> SHE DIDN'T FIX IT?
IT.
>> SHE PUT HIM BACK IN JAIL ON A
PAROLE VIOLATION.
THERE WAS A CLEAR LINE.
IT'S NOT WE SHOULD BE LOCKING
EVERYONE UP AND SENATOR COTTON
TWEETED THERE'S AN
UNDERINCARCERATION PROBLEM.
I DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE THINK
THAT.
>> I DO.
>> I DEFINITELY DO BUT THAT'S
JUST ME.
>> OKAY.
SO IT IS JUST YOU.
>> AND ME.
>> IT'S NOT.
THE ONLY PEOPLE DEMOCRATS WANT
TO LOCK UP ARE REPUBLICANS.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> YES, IT IS.
ALL THEY PROSECUTE IS TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AND TRUMP PEOPLE.
>> AMEN.
>> LOOK WHAT THE DA HERE IS
DOING AND ALWAYS GOING AFTER
TRUMP GUYS.
MAYBE IF THEY STOP GOING AFTER
TRUMP PEOPLE THAT CAN GO AFTER
THE REAL CRIMINALS.
>> WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT THERE
THEY SAID IN MY EAR.
>> OKAY.
UP